[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferris welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show this is
your host Tim Ferriss obviously and my
guest today I'm very excited to have
this guest with us today Dr Christopher
M Palmer Dr Christopher Palmer is a
Harvard psychiatrist and researcher
working at the interface of metabolism
and mental health and he probably
doesn't know this but I have wanted to
have him on for probably six to 12
months and have been looking for the
right window in the right context we'll
come back to that Dr Palmer is the
director of the Department of
postgraduate and continuing education at
McLean Hospital and an assistant
professor of Psychiatry at Harvard
Medical School for over 25 years he has
held administrative educational research
and clinical roles in Psychiatry at
Harvard he has been pioneering the use
of the medical ketogenic diet in the
treatment of psychiatric disorders
conducting research in this area
treating patients writing and speaking
around the world on this topic he has
developed the first comprehensive theory
of what causes mental illness
integrating existing theories and
Research into one unifying Theory the
brain energy theory of mental illness
you can learn more a lot more and read
many fascinating case studies in his new
book Brain energy subtitle a
revolutionary breakthrough in
understanding mental health and
improving treatment for anxiety
depression OCD PTSD and more you can
find them on Twitter and Instagram at
chrispalmer MD and you can find all
things Chris Palmer at Chris
palmermd.com Chris welcome to the show
it's so nice to see you it's great to be
here Tim thanks I need to give credit
where credit is due to Dr Dominic
D'Agostino who first put your work on my
radar and within several minutes of
watching a closed session video
within which you spoke on stage with one
of your patients I knew this podcast had
to happen and that's in part because I
think we will find a very curious
overlap a Venn diagram of your clinical
work and exploration of research and
some of my own personal experiences so
in a sense this is a very selfish
Endeavor for me because I am so eager to
learn more about your work and why don't
we begin right in the action with a case
study could you please tell the story
and I do not know the full story at all
I really just have a prompt in front of
me
and that is the story of a 70 year old
woman who had chronic paranoid
schizophrenia for 53 years
why don't we start there if you wouldn't
mind
I'm gonna actually use her real name
because she gave me permission to use
her real name and the book I call her
Mildred but
her real name is Doris
and Doris had a horrible childhood she
had a lot of PTSD depression other
things at by the time she turned 17 she
was diagnosed with schizophrenia
she had daily hallucinations and
delusions over the ensuing decades she
tried numerous
antipsychotics mood stabilizers
antidepressants and other medicines
none of them worked to stop her symptoms
she slowly but surely gained massive
amounts of weight
and
you know by the time she was 68 she
was miserable hated herself hated her
life
from the ages of 68 to 70 she tried to
kill herself at least six times and was
hospitalized for those suicide attempts
and at the age of 70 she was referred to
a weight loss clinic at Duke University
where they were using the ketogenic diet
as a weight loss method
and she decided to give it a try for
whatever reason and within two weeks not
only did she begin losing weight
but she spontaneously reported that her
long-standing auditory hallucinations
were going away
within months all of her symptoms of
schizophrenia were in full and complete
remission
within six months she was off all
psychiatric medications and remained in
full and complete remission
Doris went on
to live for another 15 years
she lost 150 pounds so the weight loss
thing was Secure but much more important
she remained symptom-free from symptoms
of schizophrenia she remained off
psychiatric medications
she remained out of psychiatric
hospitals she's never tried to kill
herself again
and when I last spoke with her she
actually
said she was happy to be alive
she attributed her
she attributed her recovery primarily to
God that she really felt that it was a
miracle from God
and uh and she asked me to tell her
story far and wide to anyone who would
listen in the hopes that it might help
even one other human being spare the
suffering she endured for decades
sadly Doris passed away this past
January of coveted pneumonia
that's an incredible Story I mean it's
it's an incredible story and a whole lot
of levels and blessed people say
that's an N of one I find it fascinating
but the plural of anecdote does not
equal data there are not only many other
case studies and I'm I'm familiar with
some of your clinical case studies but
there seems to be
an increasingly high volume of
literature
studies
and other evidence to support some of
the mechanisms that you're exploring
with your patients
and before we get to exploring some of
the mechanisms which I have quite a few
questions about because I'm so
personally interested and for those who
don't know I have had lifelong
challenges related to hereditary
depression and other
psychiatric I hesitate to call them
disorders but that's probably I mean the
most awkward but appropriate label at
the moment
let's dive into some of your personal
history and I think perhaps an easy way
to do that is to
look at the dedication start with the
dedication of your new book brand Energy
and this dedication is to your mother
and it reads my feudal attempts to save
you from the ravages of mental illness
lit a fire in me that burns to this day
I'm sorry I didn't figure this out in
time to help you may you rest in peace
if you're open to it would you mind
sharing the backstory on that dedication
I haven't really done this publicly
yet but
so my mom actually is a woman who had
two lives
and
the first part of her life up until
about age 42
was that she wanted a
simple
middle class
family life she and my father wanted a
big family they were catholic
they wanted four kids they ended up with
eight kids
and uh you know it's Catholic thing
that's all she wanted my father was a
pharmacist he started his own Pharmacy
and he needed help so she helped him she
she and he both worked 12-hour days six
days a week
to get that Pharmacy started she would
always take the youngest kid with her to
work she was often breastfeeding one of
them but that was the life she wanted
when she was 42
some horrible stuff happened in her
family
of origin with her you know her siblings
and you know everyone
all Beyond her control she had nothing
to do with any of it
but it put enormous stress and burden on
her
and she had what she called a nervous
breakdown that's what how it started and
I think it started with what we would
call depression
it quickly led to depression with
suicidal ideation
and then shortly thereafter it led to
psychotic symptoms she began to think
that she was Mary Magdalene reincarnated
she thought the world was ending she
thought this priest that she had gone to
for counseling was Jesus Christ
reincarnated
and it was the second coming of Christ
and she was somehow involved
she would get paranoid and she she
became convinced that my father was
actually the the actual devil incarnate
and
that led to them getting divorced
and the divorce courts were not kind to
her at all
she lost everything
she lost
all of her savings she got none of it
she didn't get any partial ownership of
the business she had worked her ass off
to help start
and she lost custody of all eight kids
I was I think about 13 when that
happened and
I knew she was gonna die
um and so I went to live with her
and it was not a good scene it was not
good at all
um we were actually homeless for a while
so
my first day of high school
was from a homeless shelter
and
I could go on and on
but the fast forward of her story is
that she lived the rest of her life with
a psychotic disorder
she never got better
her life was decimated
she was able to take care of herself
which was great she worked various
part-time jobs and bought a small home
and paid for it with her own money
and she inherited a chunk of money from
my grandfather like a hundred thousand
dollars but she was extraordinarily
Frugal so that was enough for her to
live on for pretty much the rest of her
life
and she you know she had obesity and
diabetes and eventually a massive heart
attack and died of heart failure
thank you for being willing to share
that
sure
it's hard to say anything of course
and I hesitate to even follow that with
anything but
number one I'm grateful that you shared
it because I think it
informs who you are and it informs the
work that you do in the world and
has helped to forge this drive and
passion and dedication that you have
with your clients
and I have to imagine with the many case
studies and the many more certainly that
have not been discussed publicly for a
million different reasons that you have
helped save
a lot of people from
life sentences to psychotic disorders
and my hope with this conversation
it's not even really a hope it is a hope
but it's almost a certainty that people
will be listening who are either
directly affected personally or directly
affected with family members or somehow
indirectly affected by what we would
consider psychiatric disorders or
psychotic disorders it's it is
incredibly incredibly prevalent and
this might be a clumsy segue but I do
think it could be a helpful one
especially for those who feel lost in a
world of
infinite information and conflicting
advice let's begin with definitions so
could you
explain your position on well first
defining what the DSM-5 diagnostic
categories are what this is is a tool
and then your your current evaluation or
perspective on DSM-5 diagnostic
categories
DSM-5 is kind of the Bible of Psychiatry
and it's what all mental health
professionals have to use to make a
diagnosis if you want to treat patients
and get reimbursed by insurance you have
to assign a diagnostic label if no label
is assigned you don't get paid
if pharmaceutical companies want to
develop pills for psychiatric disorders
they have to abide by these labels
and study pills for specific labels
and the assumption is that these labels
are all discrete separate
illnesses
and they Define a set of symptoms but
more importantly they Define a prognosis
and a life trajectory sometimes they
also Define treatments that can work and
treatment approaches and how long people
might need treatment
and in many of those ways the diagnostic
labels are actually useful and I'm not
here to challenge any of that I think
understanding what symptoms people are
having and understanding what treatments
might be helpful to reduce those
symptoms is actually really invaluable
and that's great
but the reality is that every diagnostic
label in DSM is a syndrome
and what that means is that no it's just
a constellation of signs and symptoms
that we put together
and no one knows what causes any of them
and
the real answer is that when when
researchers have looked
at all of the diagnostic categories
it turns out that there are two major
problems with DSM
and the two major problems with DSM are
heterogeneity and comorbidity
and what that means is so heterogeneity
means that if you see two people with
OCD or with autism spectrum disorder
they can have extraordinarily different
symptoms and look and function very
differently from each other and it can
seem like there's no way they have the
same brain disorder or brain illness or
whatever we want to call it
so that's heterogeneity the comorbidity
part is even more confusing because it
turns out if you have one psychiatric
disorder and you're getting mental
health treatment
there is an overwhelming probability
that you have more than one
and you can mix and match them however
you like
and this is really important because
it implies that maybe our diagnostic
labels number one are not valid
constructs
and number two maybe our diagnostic
labels are not as distinct as we think
they are because when you know if I look
at people with eating disorders and
they're all more likely to have
depression and OCD
but I look at people with schizophrenia
and they're all more likely to have
depression and OCD and I look at people
with personality disorders and they're
more likely to have depression and OCD
the the boundaries between these
diagnostic labels really start to fall
apart and and you kind of start to
wonder what's going on
much more importantly when we look at
the root causes the root causes that we
do know about for mental disorders it
turns out there is no single root cause
for any
singular psychiatric diagnosis and this
goes all the way down to the level of
genetics
specific genes even do not confer risk
there is no one gene that confers risk
for only one disorder like schizophrenia
or bipolar or Autism one gene confers
risk for numerous different disorders
so there might be one gene that confers
risk for schizophrenia and bipolar and
autism and epilepsy and other diagnoses
and so even if you look at a single root
cause like something so concrete is a
gene
they're not distinct entities and the
reality is that the National Institute
of Health abandoned the DSM-5 diagnoses
about a decade ago recognizing these
aren't valid constructs and we're not
really getting anywhere assuming they
are
man but it's uh
it's a pitch to get insurance
reimbursement if you don't have the
right codes to work with I guess
absolutely absolutely got to play the
game I suppose you know when you're
talking about the
no one gene conferring singularly
increased risk for one isolated
psychiatric disorder I was thinking wow
I gotta buy one get one free with my
card that I pulled from the deck buy one
get for free ah that would look
absolutely so this begs all sorts of
questions
including what
are if any the plausible underlying
mechanisms that could explain these
constellations of comorbidities
and
perhaps we we could start with the
ketogenic diet and just how it landed on
your radar and I understand the scope of
your research and work is far beyond
the ketogenic diet but I think it may be
a useful wedge for working into some
some valuable terrain how did that first
end up on your radar was it because of
patients like
Doris remembering her name correctly who
were
by not necessarily happenstance but
outside of of your care were sent to
weight loss clinics using the ketogenic
diet and you observed these ancillary
but very powerful benefits and how did
your familiarity develop from there
so my familiarity actually began with my
own story so I I told you a little bit
about my mom and
you know when I went to live with her
even before that happened I had my own
challenges with mental
illness and uh after I went through that
hell with her uh and homelessness and
everything else uh it only spiraled down
and by the time that I was in my 20s
I actually had gotten to a good place I
was not clinically depressed anymore
I I didn't I wasn't impaired I was
actually getting through medical school
I had finished Medical School actually
won an award for being one of the top
students
and and I was doing my Psychiatry
residency
at Harvard and so you know anybody
looking from the outside would say this
guy's doing well enough he's like he
clearly is not impaired by a mental
disorder
but I had metabolic syndrome so blood
pressure was up
cholesterol and lipid levels were awful
I had pre-diabetes and year after year
my doctor kept telling me diet and
exercise I was doing a super low-fat
diet I was exercising regularly it was
not doing anything it was the all the
numbers were just getting worse
and he finally kept pushing meds and was
like you're gonna have to go on meds and
I'm like
damn dude I'm like in my 20s and you're
putting you're putting me on meds
already and that means I'm gonna have a
heart attack by the time I turn 45 like
that is not okay and I am not going to
accept this as my final answer and so
I'd heard through the grapevine about
low carb diets at that point it was the
Atkins diet and I had heard that it was
helping some people reverse their
diabetes or improve their cholesterol
levels and other things
it went against everything I'd been
taught and uh but I decided to give it a
shot
really just kind of is my Hail Mary pass
and within three months
my metabolic syndrome was completely
gone
everything was better
but the thing that I notice
was I had dramatic Improvement in mood
energy sleep confidence
I became a different person a person I
had never been in my entire life even
during good times I had never felt that
good
so I of course I'm you know recommending
this to friends and family who want to
lose weight or shed a few pounds and
some of them are reporting equal results
So within a couple years I start using
it in patients with treatment resistant
depression
and lo and behold it worked for at least
some of them it didn't work for everyone
but it worked for some of them
I think the pivotal moment that really
changed everything for me was actually
in 2016 when I had a long-standing
patient schizoaffective disorder which
is crossed between schizophrenia and
bipolar
and he asked for my help to lose weight
he had tried 17 different medications
none of them worked he was tormented by
his illness in similar ways to Doris
I start this diet within two weeks he's
losing weight and I start to notice this
antidepressant effect in him
I'm like well that's interesting
within six to eight weeks he too
spontaneously start it didn't happen
right away for him took six to eight
weeks but he spontaneously reports
hallucinations delusions are going away
you know that man went on to lose 160
pounds he kept it off to this day and
has had a new life has had the ability
to do things he had not been able to do
so to kind of get back to your question
those those were the serendipitous
things that just happened in my life
that I I didn't set out on a path to
like prove the ketogenic diet is a
thoughtful intervention right because
it's snuck in the side door totally it
actually snuck in the side door and
smacked me in the face I was like what
the hell is going on here like this this
is impossible and you know for people
who know the keto diet is like a fad
weight loss diet or whatever it it is a
100 year old evidence-based treatment
for epilepsy and that was a really
important clue to me because we use
epilepsy treatments in Psychiatry all
the time
um you know medications like Depakote
Tegretol Lamictal Topamax Valium
Klonopin Xanax all of those are
anti-seizure treatments and we use them
in tens if not hundreds of millions of
people worldwide all the time
and so I quickly recognize well wait if
this diet actually stops seizures
and we use anti-seizure treatments all
the time maybe maybe that's the reason
it's working and wow this is shocking
because it's like really working
and then I learned about the Decades of
Neuroscience research that we have
documenting what exactly the ketogenic
diet is doing to the brain changes
neurotransmitters changes calcium
channel regulation changes gene
expression actually the gut microbiome
is involved inflammation it's doing all
sorts of things
and armed with all of that information
my career took off it like I started
doing you know more research
collaborating with researchers around
the world and everything else
is it fair this term came up in the
video that I watched in fact the
conference name I think had at least
some descriptor of this metabolic
Psychiatry is that a fair description of
at least a component of what you do or
would you use a different label I think
metabolic psychiatry
is definitely an emerging field
there are lots of researchers
neuroscientists clinicians
philanthropists backing this right now
the bizuki brain research fund funded by
David and Jan bazooki
founders of Roblox
they are really backing this with
passion
I think at the end of the day the brain
energy theory is bigger than just
Psychiatry the brain energy theory is
about metabolism ultimately mitochondria
and how it affects human health
and how that can have an impact on the
brain but it's more than the brain I
mean you know the brain is part of the
human body and the human body impacts
the brain
and so I'm actually more interested in
like the big picture like if you climb
the mountain and look down or if you see
the entire forest from the trees you see
the big picture we're really talking
about
a new way to understand human health
and
that includes mental health but it also
easily segues into physical health so
my only qualm with metabolic Psychiatry
is that it's focused on Psychiatry and I
am a psychiatrist I'm passionate about
helping people with mental disorders
make no mistake I'm not looking to start
a weight loss clinic for just any Joe or
Jane who want to lose weight that's not
really my passion but yeah I am going to
be helping people lose weight and
improve their physical abilities and
prevent cancer and prevent diabetes or
reverse diabetes so it's more than
psychiatry
yeah the Cartesian mind-body Duality
doesn't actually pan out very well when
uh everything is connected with blood
vessels and so on and so forth so let's
let's take a closer look at some of the
outcomes and I'll share some of my
personal history as a way of
making that segue
so I have experimented with the
ketogenic diet
since ninety
6 or 97 I would say and initially
experimented with the ketogenic diet a
cyclical ketogenic diet with one day of
carbohydrate loading following a
glycogen depletion workout it's a bit of
a long story for athletic purposes so I
was using it to
lose body fat and improve my body
composition while maintaining some
degree of muscular growth and anabolism
by spiking insulin once a week with this
carbohydrate loading and it worked
spectacularly well I was using it for
athletic performance but
much later now I've done a fair amount
of fasting quite a bit of ketogenic
dieting and when people ask me for fat
loss there are many options there are
actually quite a few really good options
but the point I make is if you suffer
from depression or anxiety personally I
have found nothing
close
to as dramatic as the ketogenic diet for
eliciting a significant change and it's
so noticeable for me that if I'm using
say the
and Abbott Labs Precision extra device
to measure
Ketone concentrations and millimolars
predictably based on how I feel in terms
of not just mood but mental acuity so
speed of cognitive turnover I know it's
not a technical term just speed of
computation short-term memory I can tell
when my body clicks over past say 0.7
millimolars predictably I can guess
where I am between 0.7 and say 1.0
millimolars based on mood and cognition
and furthermore over the span of several
days and typically I Kickstart ketosis
with a period of fasting I just find
that the the easiest for me personally
but I recognize the the sort of
adherence challenges that can pose for a
lot of folks
I also seem to and this is leading to a
question don't worry I also noticed that
when I am in reasonably
established ketosis because
I think a lot of people think they're in
ketosis when they're
eating a ketogenic meal once a day and
that that we can get to but uh when I am
measurably in ketosis my need for Sleep
also goes down dramatically and I would
say I wake up whether I want to or not
after six hours of sleep and I feel
fully refreshed I don't experience the
morning grogginess that I typically do
the question is what the hell is going
on so biochemically
from a
genetic on off switch perspective what
what is happening in the body that
contributes to some of these experiences
and effects
a brilliant question and I don't think
we have all the answers because this is
a relatively new field and in terms of
looking at the effects of the ketogenic
diet on mental States
and certainly in terms of looking at it
in terms of people with exclusive or
primary mental disorders you know
researchers have looked at it for other
things
so the first thing I'll say is you're
actually everything you described is
spot on with what I see clinically in
dozens of patients and what I hear from
patients around the world
and it's one of the challenges I want to
point this out you're you're
highlighting the decreased need for
sleep is one of the biggest risks of
using this intervention in people who
have had a history of psychosis
and the reason is because
you know for you it sounds like it has
not been a major problem
I've definitely seen people who have
gotten hypomanic while they especially
while they're keto adapting to the point
that they're actually only getting two
hours of sleep a night and uh they can't
sleep more than that
and sometimes they recognize this may
not be optimal for me and other times
they just think well you know I've got a
lot of time now to be productive and get
all sorts of [ __ ] done so uh I mean one
guy actually was going for 20 mile runs
starting at like 3 A.M in the morning
and uh and and he complained that he he
couldn't maintain a normal weight and he
wondered why and I'm like dude you're
like sleeping two hours a night and
you're running 20 miles every day what
did you expect
um some basic math
can explain this yeah yeah absolutely
you know the effects on sleep are
complicated because some studies
like in epilepsy patients for instance
have found that the ketogenic diet
actually dramatically improves sleep
overall
but a lot of those patients are sleeping
too much and often because they're on
medications that are extraordinarily
sedating
and so those studies come to the
conclusion ketogenic diet improves sleep
it normalizes it people wake up feeling
more refreshed it's a great thing
this issue of hypomania and Mania is
very poorly understood I'm one of the
only people in the planet who seems to
recognize it as hypomania Mania so we've
got a lot of work to do in terms of
understanding it I'll give you an
evolutionary speculation about what I
think is happening widely speculative we
don't have the research for this
but I've seen this a lot not just with
ketogenic diet but with anything that
induces a kind of ketosis and a fasting
state or a fasting mimicking state so
I've seen this in patients who fast for
five seven days or whatever
and and there are actually some studies
in
Muslim patients during Ramadan
especially patients who have bipolar
disorder during Ramadan they start
fasting they are much much more likely
to have sleep problems and they are much
much more likely to have subsequent mood
episodes but primarily hypomanic and
manic but also depressive for some
people
so I think that we've got enough
evidence and I certainly have enough
anecdotal evidence to say
decreased sleep is a thing it's a real
thing it's observed uh we've got some
studies to document it why would the
body need less sleep or why would the
body get less sleep
while in a ketogenic State my assumption
is just going with a common sense
evolutionary perspective which is the
body thinks it's actually
starving it's it's drought there's a
there's a drought or famine or something
something is going on food supply is
scarce that's why you have high ketones
and so the high ketones are actually
activating brain regions to get you
number one more energy more confidence
and the more time you don't need to be
sleeping right now you've got to find
food and find it fast and so it gives
people more energy to actually go out
seek explore hunt whatever
looking for food sources
again wild speculation but at least in
my mind it kind of makes sense
from an evolutionary perspective
definitely it makes sense and does the
mood Improvement
reflect in your opinion
increased release of norepinephrine or
something along those lines or is it
remedying via ketones this alternate
fuel source which the brain and the
heart and other some other tissues
really love
is the presence of ketones remedying and
underlying glucose metabolism disorder
that is in part causal
with the conditions that end up getting
pulled from the DSM-5 how would you
explain even if it's just a tentative
hypothesis the mood elevation that
people experience because it is it is so
noticeable it is not subtle for me in
the least
I will share my personal story too when
because I've been in and out of ketosis
for many years and I find the exact same
thing
and quite honestly sometimes the Sleep
the inability to sleep or sleep an
adequate amount of time is the rate
limiting factor for me and I'm like I
can't I can't go with this little sleep
for this long this is not going to turn
out well for me if I stay on this
trajectory I know enough you know there
are lots of people with lots of
different opinions and we we know at
least like 40 different mechanisms of
action of the ketogenic diet like I said
neurotransmitters all sorts of things so
how exactly is it resulting in this
improved mood
there's going to be debate I actually
firmly believe based on this larger
Theory and kind of connecting all of the
dots
I actually firmly believe that it really
does come down to
mitochondria and some people call it
mitochondrial dysfunction
there's another group of researchers
that like to call it sub-optimal
mitochondrial function
um wouldn't want to upset those
mitochondria because that's different
than dysfunction whatever it what it
what it means at the end of the day and
we may get to this mitochondria are
actually much much more than just
powerhouses but Powerhouse function is a
critically important function and we
have evidence from numerous
data sources
from blood work from you know lumbar
punctures from autopsy studies
to all of the neuroimaging studies that
we're doing functional MRI pet scan spec
scans all of these studies
all of them Converge on mitochondria and
functions of mitochondria and what all
of these studies suggest is that people
with mental disorders
across the board
tend to have
regions of the brain so it's not an it's
not the entire body like metabolism is
cell specific and tissue specific so you
can have one cell that's actually ready
to die because it's metabolically
failing you can have another brand new
healthy cell that's actually thriving in
the same human body
so it's important to keep that in mind
but
what all of this research says is that
some braid regions in some people are
metabolically compromised their brain
tissue is not getting enough energy and
it also has higher levels of reactive
oxygen species which can produce
inflammation and all sorts of problems
but we know this and again tons of
evidence and different lines of evidence
all pointing in the same direction even
genetic studies like when you look at
well what is this Gene doing and what
what's happening in the brains of people
with these genetic defects you time and
again see mitochondrial or metabolic
impairment or dysfunction
and what I think the ketogenic diet is
doing is it is
I imagine a cell
that's only running on it's a six
cylinder engine and it's only running on
three cylinders
and you give it ketones and ketones are
like rocket fuel for this engine and all
of a sudden all six cylinders come
online
and that cell is firing and
for most people that's a good thing and
it gives people energy and everything
else if that metabolically compromised
cell actually is in great disrepair if
it is like really miserably
maintained and in great disrepair giving
it all this Rocket Fuel all at once can
actually be really dangerous and can
result in a whole host of other symptoms
could you elaborate on what a dangerous
case would look like because presumably
we're not talking about and please
correct me if we're on ketoacidosis
right in the case of say a type 1
diabetic who has comorbidities and they
have high ketones and high glucose
dangerous situation in what way or in
what fashion would this
manifest is dangerous so one of the
consequences of metabolic dysfunction of
a cell you know one of the big themes
there are several consequences I kind of
break them into five buckets depending
on where and when there are two primary
ones for an adult say who is just going
you know who's developing new onset
symptoms
and the shocking thing is that they're
Polar Opposites so the cell can either
become under active
which means it's failing to work because
it doesn't have enough energy and that
makes sense Common Sense really easy to
understand but the other consequence of
metabolic dysfunction is actually that
cell can become what's called hyper
excitable it can actually become
overactive
and you know some easy examples of
overactive or hyper-excitable cells are
a muscle spasm or a heart arrhythmia or
somebody with chronic pain who's
experiencing pain because their pain
nerve is hyper excitable it's firing
when it really shouldn't be firing or
it's not stopping when it should stop
and so metabolically compromised cells
are prone to this hyperexcitability
and the challenge with ketones for some
people is that you you rush in this
Ultra Clean kind of high octane fuel
and the cell becomes hyper excitable and
the way that translates in terms of
brain function is it for somebody who's
got a hyper excitable or a metabolically
compromised anxiety pathway or anxiety
system they could have a panic attack or
feel more anxious early on
but for other people it can result in
psychosis it can result in OCD symptoms
it can result in all sorts of things
agitation
the extreme case of hyper excitability
in the brain is actually a seizure
well the more you know folks be careful
out there so so mitochondria just to
underscore mitochondria for a moment so
the powerhouses of the cell I mean the
origin story of mitochondria we can
leave aside I mean it's fascinating just
to look into how we ended up with
mitochondria in our bodies but
for the purposes of this conversation
the powerhouses of the cell I think it's
what oxidative phosphorylation they
generate
the vast majority are all of ATP
adenosine triphosphates let's just
consider that for our purposes and feel
free to pick this apart but the Basic
Energy
of the Body for
most people most of the time there are a
bunch of exceptions
the reason mitochondrial function and
dysfunction is of great interest to me
personally is not just because of the
depression but a pet Theory slash
hypothesis that I developed after a
severe case of Lyme disease about eight
to ten years ago I don't remember the
exact timing I grew up on Eastern Long
Island everybody gets Lyme disease
almost everybody my mom also has the
alpha galactose allergy inflicted by an
infection from the lone star tick so she
can have anaphylactic shock if she
consumes any mammalian protein including
gelatin which isn't everything so I grew
up surrounded by ticks and tick-borne
disease and I developed very severe Lyme
symptoms it was confirmed through a
number of different tests as a Lyme
infection there are other co-infections
but let's focus on Lyme for the minute
and
the first thing that this lab told me
was number one you're aware you've
already had lime are you not and they
highlighted the fact that I had
long-term antibodies which raised
questions for me about
whether my depressive episodes which
started around adolescence were in fact
as simple I mean that's probably not the
right word as a hereditary
genetic predisposition which there
appears to be a component of that at
least based on my genome sequencing
or if in addition to that maybe a
catalyst or accelerant was this first
infection with Lyme disease and the
reason I mentioned that is the second
time I had Lyme disease and the symptoms
I made a very significant mistake and
that was I looked for the bullseye rash
the bullseye rash didn't appear and
therefore I didn't start any type of
antibiotic treatment
and it turned out this is going
somewhere don't worry it's a little
long-winded but it'll go somewhere that
even without the Dermatological symptoms
many people can be dermatologically
asymptomatic and still develop Lyme
disease which is exactly what happened
to me and the only reason I wanted to
get tested is my speech started to slur
I was forgetting
close friends names common words it was
taking me five to ten minutes to get out
of bed in the morning because my joints
were so in so much pain from
inflammation
and I went through all of the standards
of care I I did the antibiotics which
had some effect
but I was in this
energetic No Man's Land I was incredibly
fatigued all the time I felt as a result
I these two things are often correlated
for me depressed what I would describe
as depressed
and
I continued to have what felt like
dementia on some level for probably six
to six to nine months until I decided
and I can't remember what catalyzed this
I don't think it was the lime but I did
a week-long extended fast and by
two and a half days in and I was
measuring my Ketone levels which I think
is actually really helpful if if people
are trying to get a grasp on these
things
all of those symptoms literally vanished
by the time I got to 1.2 1.3 millimolars
and
and not only did the symptoms evaporate
but
I continued to fast and then I continued
on a sub caloric ketogenic diet for a
period of time afterwards
and that was an effect and again I'm not
a doctor I don't play one on the
internet so I'm not giving medical
advice but this approach with with lime
and
ketogenic diet has now been replicated
across probably half a dozen of my
friends
I should say this is true Lyme disease
and not someone who is dissatisfied with
life and depressed and diagnosis
shopping for Lyme disease looking for an
external cause which is a different
story
but in this case
once I saw the remission of symptoms and
then I got off of the ketogenic diet
with the well-founded fear that I would
revert back to my previous state I did
not revert to my previous state so
that's probably explaining that maybe
beyond the grasp or beyond the scope of
this conversation but
what that raised for me as a question
was
are the symptoms of Lyme disease caused
by some type of impairment of
mitochondrial function or glucose
metabolism
it just seemed like a very fair question
to ask and I know this isn't an
interview about Lyme disease but
what should we know about mitochondria
if someone is not familiar with
mitochondria or maybe they just have the
basics like I laid out
what do you find interesting about
mitochondria or perhaps aspects of
mitochondria that would be helpful for
this conversation
so sorry for the Ted Talk thanks for
listening no worries it's a perfect
segue into this so
the real answer is that mitochondria
connect all of the dots of every Factor
known to play a role in mental illness
whether it's neurotransmitters stress
trauma hormones
all of them and I'll I can come back to
them if you want but let me follow up on
your story so you had an infection high
levels of inflammation those high levels
of inflammation are good
they're good for your body because your
body is being assaulted by
this bacterium these bacteria and it's
it's going to kill you if your body
doesn't mount a defense
so the inflammation that you were
experiencing was good and healthy
but yes it made you feel like [ __ ] and
it impaired your brain function
we have direct evidence that
inflammation and inflammatory cytokines
and specific ones
actually impair mitochondrial function
and or change mitochondrial gene
expression
so we know that that's happening
for the most part that might be
a normal adaptive response because again
your body's mounting a defense for its
survival and so it's allocating
resources to fighting off this bacteria
and that means resources need to come
away from somewhere else
some cells are going to suffer as a
result of the need to fight off this
life-threatening thing
and we have direct evidence that some
brain cells have a reduction in
mitochondrial function
I think for people who are already on
the edge people who've had depression in
the past maybe people who have a genetic
vulnerability
or other type of vulnerability that
reduction
can be too much for them because those
brain cells are already maybe operating
at slightly reduced capacity or even
maybe moderately reduced capacity and
then when you throw an infection on top
of it it just pushes those cells over
the edge and then they begin to
malfunction and that results in what we
call symptoms of mental illness
it's not just Lyme disease though so
we've got lots of research Decades of
research
showing that inflammation especially
from infections
can result in brain disorders mental
disorders neurological disorders we we
know this with certainty so one study
looked at kids who developed an
infection that was serious enough to be
hospitalized and they had like an 80 80
something percent increased risk of
developing a mental disorder most of
them within the three months following
hospitalization and the mental disorders
were across the board these kids in the
next three months developed autism
schizophrenia OCD
learning disabilities seizures all sorts
of problems which again is consistent
with this more unifying model of how to
think about mental illness these aren't
discrete entities but they're obviously
discrete symptoms and symptoms matter
well I can stop there or I can share two
no no I'll keep going I'll share I'll
share one or two tidbits to highlight
why mitochondria are so important to
this Theory yeah please so one
neurotransmitters everybody knows
neurotransmitters play a role in mental
illness turns out mitochondria play a
critical role in the production the
direct production but also the release
and the regulation of major
neurotransmitters including dopamine
serotonin Gaba glutamate and others so
mitochondria actually are taking food
you know broken down food whether that's
carbohydrates fats proteins and
they're converting it into two different
things primarily they're converting it
into a fuel source they're burning it
all the way down and then that fuel gets
used to create either ATP or heat
so it's fuel
or it's building blocks for other things
it's building blocks to make new
proteins or make membranes or other
things and the mitochondria are actually
producing some of the primary building
blocks for those neurotransmitters
but in fact researchers have looked at
cells
and if if they take the mitochondria out
of the synapse for instance but flood
the flood the synapse with ATP so it's
still got lots of energy
it's got energy available the
neurotransmitters actually don't get
released
the mitochondria are playing a direct
role in actually releasing the
neurotransmitters and then I'll just
share hormones too so you know everybody
has heard about you know steroid
hormones cortisol estrogen testosterone
progesterone mitochondria actually
control the first step in the synthesis
of all of those hormones and so if they
are dysfunctional if there is a problem
with mitochondria you may have a problem
with producing those hormones
wow
stars of the show top of the Marquee
mitochondria all right I'm I'm
definitely going to be doing more
reading on mitochondria now
let me ask a question or present uh
situation and a question that I imagine
is is coming on to
the minds of many people listening and
that is
Tim Ferriss
if ketogenic diets are so amazing and
you feel so much better why aren't you
always in in ketosis and
so I want to
answer that and then ask for your input
first I will just lay out that for the
Sleep piece what I've noticed to myself
this is especially true with extended
fasting is that whether the Sleep let's
just say six hours long feels restful or
not often depends on my electrolyte
consumption so if I am not consuming
carbohydrates and I'm just splitting off
tons of water because I I don't have the
retention capabilities sometimes I can
at least personally I can develop lower
back pain might be kidney related and I
think it's probably it might be a
cholinergic response I'm getting a
little outside of my depth here but in
terms of rapid heart rate trying to go
to sleep that seems to be largely
remedied by additional supplemental
electrolyte intake however the challenge
for me is often one of not dietary
compliance
I happen to be a cholesterol hyper
absorber so sometimes on the ketogenic
diet I do see my lipid profiles go
completely cuckoo bananas and for many
people that's not the case but for me I
have witnessed that so I have some
long-term considerations I'm already
taking things like zetamine to control
for some of the risk factors personally
I'm not recommending that for anybody
talk to your doctor
but for people who have no familiarity
with the ketogenic diet and you're
trying to help someone
sustain
ketosis for a period of time what
approach do you take do you use cream
like they did with children for a long
time in the studies looking at epilepsy
what is the approach that you take to
make it as easy as possible for people
to stick with it
well and I think you raise a really good
point that not everybody should be or
needs to be on a ketogenic diet or in
ketosis long term but for the patients
that I'm working with they usually have
serious brain disorders that most almost
all of them are disabled by their
symptoms
and so
like epilepsy where somebody's having
multiple seizures every single day
you know they they have a very serious
brain disorder that needs immediate and
consistent medical intervention and so
if you're using the ketogenic diet in
those situations you know most of those
patients do need it consistently and in
a way I know people want a
one-size-fits-all answer and I have to
tell you I just have to level with you
there isn't one so for an obese patient
so if I'm working with somebody who
weighs 340 pounds
I can get high levels of ketones in that
person by just carb restriction alone so
tell them to just eat less than 20 grams
of carbs a day
I don't really even have to get into any
limits on protein and I usually don't
have to recommend that they eat more fat
or fat sources because they have so much
body fat to tap into and usually in
those cases we want to tap into that
body fat because they're usually
interested in losing some of it and so
in those people I'm going to recommend
carb restriction and that's about it and
usually it's pretty easy for them to
maintain very high levels of ketones and
get the therapeutic brain effects as a
result
once that same person loses enough of
that body fat or if I have a different
patient coming to me who's already thin
or athletic
that person is going to need
to probably
you know moderate the amount of protein
they're eating and consume more fat than
they really think they should be eating
I mean
we're both laughing because I know what
that means yeah yeah no when I introduce
people to a ketogenic diet and I tell
them how much fat I want them eating
they're just like you've got to be
joking there's no way that's healthy
there's no way I can do that and but
yeah so lots of ways to do it I mean you
can create like fat bombs heavy whipping
cream is really a great tool some people
drink it straight and just you know they
drink it like milk you can actually put
a little bit of water in it to water it
down if you want it to be a little more
like milk it's also really good in
coffee really good in coffee great in
coffee it's great if you whip it and
then it's whipped cream it's delicious
you can use artificial sweeteners if you
want I usually recommend something like
Stevia or monk fruit you can put vanilla
in it you can put cocoa powder in it and
then it's chocolate or vanilla and you
can freeze it and it becomes ice cream I
mean you can do a lot of things with it
to make it palatable and and sustainable
but yeah
so do you start people off with
directions let's just say they have
lower percent body fat so they're not
necessarily bodybuilders but let's just
say they're somewhere between a 20 body
fat or less
and
assuming that means they're going to
need to modify their intake to increase
the percentage of their dietary calories
from fat would you rather than say
change each meal to have X Y and Z
composition say have supplemental fat
bombs have some supplemental heavy cream
and that's how you'll basically
move the slider such that you're getting
something like 70 of your calories from
from that not sure if that's the the
target range but you would add the fat
as opposed to change all the meals yeah
I'm usually adding the fat so low carb
is the Baseline and then
you know the the protein may need to
vary I want to make sure they're getting
adequate protein
but it's not an all-you-can-eat meat
Fest necessarily
for most people quite honestly it's
usually a work in progress because
everybody has different dietary
preferences some people like salads and
if they like salads I'm gonna say okay
have lots of salads but put some
crumbled blue cheese on it maybe some
almonds in there and avocado in there
and douse it with as much olive oil as
you can tolerate and uh and you know
whatever that is vinegar and oil a lot
of oil
that could become a very high fat thing
and some people may love that other
people hate it and so other people are
gonna lean more toward really fatty
steaks or
they want sweets in which case yeah
we're going to be doing fat bombs and
whipped cream and ice cream and other
things so it is there are lots of
strategies which is good because that
way we can like figure out what does
this person like and let's make it
sustainable
I have one friend who's an MD very very
competent MD who was in ketosis for two
years two to three years straight and
his General approach was skip breakfast
so intermittent fast maybe some coffee
with heavy cream and then have a large
salad lots of greens but in terms of
actual net carbohydrates pretty low with
steak cheese
tons of oil and then having sort of a
moderate
protein
dinner that would be on the smaller side
and
just so people know and please correct
me if I'm getting this wrong but the
reason a lot of folks have an aversion I
think a lot of it is cultural
conditioning to attempt to do ketosis by
simply going low carb
and they end up going very very high
protein so they think that they can do
you know green salad with like a
mountain of lean chicken breast and make
it work but the body's really crafty it
happens to like ATP so the body will
take the excess protein or a portion of
it and convert it in the liver I think
through a process called gluconeogenesis
to glucose so that oops you end up not
being able to sustain the higher levels
of ketones because your body just does
not need them if you have high glucose
levels your body is is getting what it
needs and your body's pretty smart about
resource allocation definitely feel free
if there's anything you'd like to add to
that any other common mistakes that you
observe or things that people don't
think will affect ketosis that tends to
affect ketosis in unexpected ways any
common pitfalls you'd like to highlight
you know honestly there are so many uh
and I it's hard to it's hard to it's
hard to put them into one category
the nice thing about the ketogenic diet
is that there is an objective measure of
whether you're doing it right or not and
it's measure your ketones yeah if you're
able to measure your blood ketones
measure your blood ketones
and then do the detective work to figure
out why you're not achieving the results
you want and you know with a variety of
patients so the detective work which
gets to your exact question like what
are the pitfalls I've seen people eating
a lot of keto labeled junk food from the
grocery store Costco keto brownies all
day long it's got keto on the label so
it must be okay and it's filled with
soluble corn fiber and you know sugar
alcohols and other stuff that clearly is
not necessarily natural and lo and
behold takes a lot of people out of
ketosis and prevents weight loss and
prevents the brain benefits and lots of
other things that you want to be
achieving so that's probably the single
biggest Pitfall is all the keto labeled
junk food yeah if it seems too good to
be true folks probably is I remember
doing keto way back in you know 97 98 99
and man the landscape was Barren I mean
it was pork rinds and
and heavy cream and that meat and eggs
and water and unsweetened iced tea that
was basically it but you can make it
work
let me ask you about a note I have in
front of me which I would love to hear
you elaborate on and that is some
psychiatric medications impair
metabolism even though they can reduce
some of these symptoms of presumably
Associated disorders in the short run
could you speak to that maybe give
examples because this is
this is certainly deeply interesting to
me
so let me at least preface this
discussion with kind of a caution up
front so I'm going to say some things
that may get people really upset
and especially if you're on these
psychiatric medications
and I want to just say for the record it
is really difficult and dangerous to get
off psychiatric medications especially
if you've been on them for years or
decades so please do not stop your
medication on your own please don't
taper it on your own work with your
health care professional and do it in a
safe way
you're going to hear that I am an
advocate of sometimes trying to help
people get off medication so I'm not
trying to say You must take your meds
for the rest of your life but I'm just
saying please don't do it in a dangerous
way because lots of people end up in the
hospital or suicidal or dead yeah no DIY
folks please I know people who have
committed suicide after
stopping things cold turkey or
attempting to taper but not informing
their doctors so please be very careful
and only do any type of removal of meds
with professional supervision thank you
so with that said this is probably going
to be
the single most controversial part of
the theory
because what I'm ultimately what I'm
saying is that mental disorders or
metabolic disorders of the brain
and so that means metabolic impairment
in the body and or brain can result in
mental symptoms and yet we know many of
our treatments directly impair
metabolism so we know a lot of
antipsychotics mood stabilizers even
some antidepressants and others
cause people to gain weight sometimes
massive amounts of weight they can cause
type 2 diabetes they can cause
cardiovascular disease and all of the
risk factors for cardiovascular disease
so they can cause
hypertension it can cause abnormal
lipids
which we think contribute to
cardiovascular disease and those are all
metabolic problems that's not
controversial at all they're metabolic
problems these pills are causing these
metabolic problems they are right on the
FDA package inserts of these meds so
everything I just said is fact
non-controversial
so The Logical question from many people
is well then Chris your theory must be
wrong
because
these pills work
and
if they're impairing metabolism then
that pretty much disproves your theory
how would this make sense otherwise
and quite honestly this was actually one
of the biggest things I struggled with
in developing this Theory I I kind of
was on this path metabolism mitochondria
wow that that seems to be the connecting
that's connecting a lot of dots and that
was actually one of the obstacles for me
was that exact question like how can I
understand that and it's not that I want
to deny that the medications do reduce
symptoms because they do reduce symptoms
I've seen it work firsthand as a
psychiatrist I've seen these medications
reduce symptoms
and I'm not here to say all of the
clinical trials are a big lie and scam
from pharmaceutical companies I don't
think they are
so I had to try to understand like well
then what's going on it kind of does
disprove my theory so I've got I've got
to come up with an explanation and at
the end of the day that the explanation
is this dichotomous reaction of a cell
to metabolic impairment
so when a cell is metabolically
compromised
you know there are some other things
that it can do but the two for our
professors right now are under active or
overactive or hyper-excitable
and what we're really focused on are
hyper excitable cells so hyper-excitable
cells are producing experiences
from your brain Networks
but they're producing these experiences
at the wrong time or the wrong intensity
or they're not stopping when they should
that's what hyper excitability does so a
hyper excitable pain cell causes pain
when you shouldn't have pain a hyper
excitable brain cell is producing an
experience sensation cognition something
it should not be happening when it
happens and that could be
anxiety you know depression
hallucinations whatever
in order to stop a hyper-excitable cell
there are kind of two strategies you can
use
so one would be to slowly but surely
restore the metabolic health of that
cell through strategies that Tim you've
used yourself
exercise ketones you know fasting
meditation other things those are going
to restore metabolic Health to those
cells and allow those cells to function
normally again
but the other way to stop a hyper
excitable cell is to basically put a
straight jacket on it
and to stop it from functioning almost
all together
and that's what a lot of the pills that
we prescribe are doing they are
impairing mitochondrial function
so that that cell has trouble firing at
all
and that means that symptoms of hyper
excitability can stop and so for some
people if you're having a panic attack
and somebody gives you a pill and it
makes that stop that can feel really
good
if you're having a seizure it can be
life-saving
if you're psychotic and violent that can
be life-saving
so I'm not trying to say these pills
should never be used or they don't have
a time and a place because they think
they do
but if you take that pill long term
that pill is like putting a straight
jacket on that cell it's suppressing the
function of that cell over the long run
and what that means is that that cell
becomes weaker over the long run
and that may very well end up making the
illness even worse in the lung run
that that is the theory there are lots
of people who have been preaching that
message for decades who are going to say
duh Chris Palmer where the hell have you
been and then there are other people who
are going to say Chris Palmer how dare
you say that that is blasphemy and you
are now a dangerous quack so I know I'm
gonna get responses from all over the
place
but if you understand the science if you
understand the basic science and all of
the evidence that is a real possibility
are there
any let's just say I don't want to say
worst offenders because that has too
much of a negative connotation but are
there any particular drugs that stand
out to you
as having a time and a place to be used
but that are particularly
powerful at disrupting
metabolic Integrity if they're used
chronically without any type of cycling
off
the easy answer is and you know I could
get into all of the science documenting
at the cellular level how and why this
has been supported
but we really don't need that the easy
answer is just look at the human being
in front of you if they are gaining
massive amounts of weight
if they feel extraordinarily slowed down
and now they're sleeping 14 hours a day
16 hours a day
and they can barely function
and their cognition is trashed
they can't think anymore they can't read
a book anymore
they can't hold a job they can't do
school
those are all signs of metabolic
impairment of brain cells so those are
the medications that I would be most
worried about and it can differ
among people if one person is taking a
medication and having all of those side
effects that I just listed and yet
another person is taking maybe a lower
dose of that same medication
and is finding it beneficial and still
able to function in life and still you
know able to do everything they want to
do and not gaining lots of weight and
not becoming type 2 diabetic
then all the power to that person and
all the power to that treatment and I
would be in full support of that
treatment and
you know I'm not at all here to deny
that treatments can work for some people
but
you know I didn't really say this but I
just want to say this in case people
think Chris Palmer is way too
pessimistic who the hell is this guy
you know the real answer is that
mental disorders
are now the leading cause of disability
on our planet
and it's not because people aren't
getting treatment
a lot of those people are getting
treatment and it's because our current
treatments fail to work for them
that is a fact
and that is why I am so passionate about
this work because I want to help those
people who are being told there's
nothing more we have to offer you
there's nothing more we can do just take
your pills and stop complaining
I want to help them
if we wanted to take a moment to act as
Patient Advocates so many
patients many people who are taking
psychiatric medications
or medications for psychiatric
conditions will not have doctors who are
familiar with the many functions and
purposes of mitochondria how the
ketogenic diet and ketones interplay
with energetic production and can
alleviate say inflammation for those
people who don't know you can find lots
of literature to support this many types
of ketones including I think beta
hydroxybutyrate is probably one of the
most obvious to search for are highly
anti-inflammatory I mean another another
observation I had went deep into ketosis
is that many of my chronic pains
decreased significantly including
tendinosis and other issues
so for people who don't have a Doctor
Who's well versed in these things but
let's assume for the moment that their
doctor is open-minded to continued
education are there any resources that
uh you would suggest I mean I would
imagine
that your book is is certainly one of
them the book being brain energy are
there other resources you might suggest
that a patient asks their doctor if
they're willing to read up on so they
can have these conversations absolutely
so you can go to my website
chrispalmermd.com or you can go to a
website that is about to Launch
brain energy.com
and I will be posting free resources
studies
lay articles so already on my website
I've got lay press articles if you just
want to better understand these
treatments and the science behind them
but I've also got links to the medical
peer reviewed literature
and that's important if you're trying to
get your Healthcare practitioner to take
this seriously and at least have a
discussion with you about using this as
a treatment option even if you can't
understand what that article is saying
because it's written in medical language
uh you can print it out and give it to
your healthcare provider and that will
build some credibility so don't go and
just say oh I saw this YouTube video on
the internet and
and it was great and I think you should
do this if you arm yourself with some of
this scientific literature you're you're
more likely to get a good response from
your Healthcare practitioner to at least
work with you or consider it with you
yeah mentioned Harvard when you
mentioned Dr Christopher Palmer and not
YouTube mentioned Harvard before you
mention YouTube Pro tip so the the next
question I'd love to ask
well actually I'll make an observation
which is not necessarily an accurate
observation but as I'm thinking about
your description of some of these common
medications that can disrupt
metabolic function sometimes to
good short-term clinical effect as you
mentioned right if somebody is psychotic
and at risk of injuring or killing
themselves
these medications have a role and if
someone is currently on these
medications let's say they recognize
some of the symptoms weight gain
lethargy
sacrificed cognition
they don't necessarily this is not
medical advice but just a hypothesis
need to rush to get off of these
medications it seems to me they could
also potentially consider adding dietary
interventions
exercise
Etc that could act as a counterbalance
so that they are facilitating some
cellular
Rejuvenation or metabolic efficiency
while they are continuing to use these
medications so it's not all or nothing
it's not
remove all of these components and then
add all these components they can be
parallel tracks is that fair to say it
is essential to say yeah when I have
patients come to me who say I want to
try this ketogenic diet thing
they stay on all their current meds
taking people off their meds is
dangerous please hear that and the way
that I think about it is it means that
those cells are now almost shriveled up
those cells are struggling because they
have been suppressed for so long so when
you take those meds away they're going
to become hyper excitable immediately as
energy rushes into those cells they're
gonna become hyper excitable and it's
like taking a cast off of a broken leg
and then saying go run it's not a good
idea the first step is exactly what you
said maybe Implement some other
strategies dietary change
ketogenic diet or otherwise sometimes
it's just let's remove all the junk food
and the sugar and some other stuff
that's inflammatory and that might be
enough of a first step for some people
but add some exercise try to get your
sleep under control and then if that is
working and especially if it's working
in a profound way then maybe slowly but
surely over time see if you can slowly
but surely taper your meds
for people who may be in my position
which is
huge fan convert
True Believer in the certainly the
psycho-emotional and I suppose we're
looking a little under the hood
energetic benefits of the ketogenic diet
but concerned about
some of the long-term cardiac effects
due to my cholesterol hyper absorption
or I should say sterile really because
des moisturol and all these other plant
sterols are also hyper absorbed which
can cause issues
what is your current position on
use of exogenous ketones or ketones
supplements
as a way to
perhaps partially achieve some of what
you have seen with dietary interventions
is it possible is it contraindicated I
always have a divided position on this
because I look at and this may be an
unfair comparison but I look at say
ketoacidosis and I think to myself it
really doesn't make sense to me
from an evolutionary perspective that it
would be good for you to have normal or
elevated glucose levels while
simultaneously pushing ketones to two or
three millimolars with exogenous Ketone
consumption that it doesn't at least at
face values seem like that would be with
our risk
how would you suggest I think about this
the real answer is I don't think anybody
knows for sure
a lot of people are really interested in
exogenous ketones and obviously it's so
much easier to drink ketones than do a
ketogenic diet yeah so no question about
that the first
fact I want to just share the first
observation I want to share is that you
know there are tens of thousands of
children with treatment resistant
epilepsy who are using ketogenic diets
to control their epilepsy
exogenous ketones have been around for
years
we do not yet have even one case report
of one child
being able to transition off a ketogenic
diet to exogenous ketones and maintain
the benefits of seizure Improvement or
seizure Freedom trust me thousands of
parents and neurologists and others have
almost certainly tried it
do I have documentation of that no
because they're not reporting it because
it didn't work out so there's no way to
really but it would be a hell of a lot
easier for everybody involved so you
have to assume they would have tried it
I have to assume reasonable I have to
assume that some of these patients with
epilepsy gave it a shot
I know it's certainty I've talked with
patients with bipolar disorder and other
disorders for instance who are using a
ketogenic diet to control their symptoms
they did try exogenous ketones went off
the diet and symptoms came back
sometimes with the vengeance
and I've used it in clinical practice as
well with patients and I've not seen a
significant benefit of exogenous ketones
so those observations make me think a
couple of things one is that the
ketogenic diet is doing a lot it's it's
improving insulin signaling it's
changing the gut microbiome improving
hormones
you know all sorts of things
but when you force your liver to make
ketones because that's where most of the
ketones in the human body are made and
interestingly they're made by
mitochondria so so it is actually the
mitochondria in the liver that are
making the ketones and help me help you
mitochondria well so one of the things
that's happening when somebody's on a
ketogenic diet is actually you're
getting this thing called mitochondrial
biogenesis in the liver which means that
your liver cells are actually making
more mitochondria to meet this demand
that's a big deal that in and of itself
might be improving the health of your
liver
and the ability of your liver
to send kind of healthier metabolic
signals to your brain and throughout
your body you know the liver plays a
profound role in terms of metabolic
health
we know that and there are lots of
signals it gets really complicated
really quickly but the bottom line is
increasing mitochondria in cells
confers health benefits pretty much
across the board as long as they're
healthy mitochondria of you increased
defective ones that's not going to do
very much but I actually sadly
think exogenous ketones are not going to
be the magic answer could they play a
role for some people probably they might
be good like on an as needed basis or
they might be a good rescue for somebody
who's using a ketogenic diet falls off
the wagon gets really sick needs a quick
rescue
maybe exogenous ketones would help that
person in that situation I don't know
yeah from a first person subjective
experience I can say having consumed a
lot of exogenous ketones of many many
different types that for
certain types of physical performance
for
physical
performance at altitude in any hypoxic
state this supplemental ketones can be
very helpful and that that applies in my
case to intermittent fasting also so if
I'm intermittent fasting and let's say I
have podcasts to record in the morning
but I haven't eaten in 12 hours whatever
it might be
sub little ketones plus some caffeine
does a lot of heavy lifting for a short
period of time but I have not
experienced the extended durable mood
elevating effects or cognitive benefits
from exogenous ketones that I have from
the ketogenic diet there's no comparison
in in my experience I do find and also
I'll sound like a broken record not
medical advice fasting it's a shame that
you just can't get extended fasting
studies in humans through
IRB these days I really wish that were
different but
don't just DIY a long-term fast folks
but for me personally when I am
segwaying into say a three-day fast
which would be my most
typical duration of fast
I have done up to 10 days but more
typically I'll I'll do three days I will
use exogenous ketones on my first day of
full fasting which is typically 12 to 18
hours after beginning a fast after an
early dinner
to allow me to eke out one more
productive day of work on a Friday the
use of exogenous ketones as a booster
shot or an accelerant that assists with
the Segway into ketosis I do find quite
helpful but I do not find it in any way
to replicate the psychological or
energetic benefits of the ketogenic diet
sadly it would be a lot easier it would
no and I think that's so helpful but it
certainly lines up with what I've seen
in other people too
now if you had to specifically and uh I
know we've been going for a while so
we're gonna probably maybe we'll do a
round two sometime but
a quick note because I thought from a
historical perspective this was
fun to see at least so
we were talking about ketogenic diet
and epilepsy
now not using the term ketogenic diet no
doubt but this this knowledge this
observation goes all the way back to
Hippocrates that fasting can stop
seizures
I always get a dumb smile plaster in my
face when I see that which is all this
once knew again in a sense I mean they
and look I mean people had humors and
spirits and all sorts of things that at
least as it stands right now we believe
to be false but it doesn't mean they got
everything wrong
so I do find the fasting maybe in the
same bucket cold baths for a depression
which were prescribed for a long time I
think there may be something to that as
well like you can do that and get some
norepinephrine in the system or you
could use a selective norepinephrine
reuptake inhibitor but really is it that
different I'm not I'm not sure
so that is a digression I just had to
mention that because I love the
historical note
in the case of schizophrenia
specifically because this this can be
such a challenging diagnosis slash
condition with the recognition that one
person next to the other both with the
same diagnosis could present very
differently
do you have any additional color to add
theories for why
this type of metabolic intervention the
ketogenic diet seems to help
specifically with schizophrenia
yeah so this goes back again to
in many ways this is nothing new folks
although this may sound new and
groundbreaking so in the 1940s some of
the first biological studies of people
with mental illness included actually
drawing blood from the veins of people
with bipolar disorder and schizophrenia
at that time they were usually labeled
the same thing
they were usually just called
schizophrenic oh man I would have been
schizophrenic also man another two for
one probably sadly be careful when
you're born folks be careful when you're
born exactly they would draw blood from
their veins and they noticed that
people with these diagnosis had higher
levels of lactate in their blood
than people who did not have a
psychiatric diagnosis and that if they
exercised them the spike in lactate was
even more pronounced
so this this difference in lactate
production has been observed for 80
years now
and that is a for those of you who don't
know this is a metabolic marker of
stress High either hypoxia which
directly stresses mitochondria because
mitochondria are the only thing in the
cell that's using oxygen
or it's it's a direct kind of indication
of mitochondrial impairment that the
mitochondria can't keep up with the
energy demands and so the cell starts
using glycolysis is kind of a backup
fuel source and Spills out lactate into
the bloodstream as consequence
now that's actually probably a really
good thing because the lactate actually
can be used as a fuel source from other
cells and so this lactate is is a signal
of metabolic stress but it's an Adaptive
response so the increased lactate we
don't want to just get rid of it and not
address the metabolic problem
but then all of the neuroimaging studies
beginning in the 1990s in particular
when we had functional neuroimaging
studies the Pet Scan specs all of the
lines of evidence we're converging on
mitochondria and you know oxidative
stress or glucose hypomatabolism or
other things in 2000 that was the year
that the first
group of researchers proposed the
mitochondrial theory of bipolar disorder
by 2004 numerous other researchers were
jumping on the bandwagon of the
mitochondrial theory of bipolar disorder
within a couple of years that quickly
segwayed also to include schizophrenia
and within a few more years that quickly
also included major depressive disorder
so depression bipolar and schizophrenia
have all had
enormous
support from numerous lines of evidence
this goes to genetic you know what do
these genetic things do like people who
have these genetic predispositions to
bipolar disorder what are those genes
actually causing
they're causing metabolic impairment in
the cells that's what they're causing
they're causing dysfunction at the
synapse which almost always includes
mitochondria because mitochondria are
hyper populated at synapses
and so in many ways the mitochondrial
theory of schizophrenia bipolar disorder
depression is actually nothing new and I
know those researchers if if this Theory
takes off those researchers are gonna be
pissed because they're gonna say like f
Chris Palmer like we we came up with
this Theory this is our Theory this is
not his theory and in many ways I fully
respect and acknowledge and I'm filled
with gratitude to all those people I
just climbed up on their shoulders and
just added to what they've been doing
like it's not like I'm creating this new
fanatical theory of what causes mental
illness I'm simply
putting all of the the foundation
together
and climbing up on other people's
shoulders
you know I'm so glad to be having this
conversation and uh I suppose not to be
too Tim Centric but in part because the
the descriptions the theories the
underlying physiology and how all these
things tie together with respect to the
presentation of in quotation marks
psychiatric disorders
mapped perfectly to my personal
experience and
you know just because Tim considers
himself an end of one doesn't uh prove
scientific truth however
it makes a lot of sense like there's no
aspect of this that to me seems out of
left field and a non-sequitur from the
understanding of basic cellular
metabolism
right it just it just makes sense to me
that sure if you have 20 children in a
preschool class and you don't feed any
of them lunch that three hours later
you're gonna have 30 grumpy kids and
each grumpy kid is going to have a
different Behavior maybe one's throwing
blocks maybe one's crying in the corner
but the underlying cause is actually
fairly straightforward and it is a
fundamental underlying cause that can
explain all of these different emergent
behaviors rather than trying to treat
the block throwing and the crying all
separately with the different
combination of drugs that is a Perfect
Analogy because right now the mental
health field says this child has block
throwing disorder this child has grumpy
disorder this child has handwriting
disorder and this child has Defiant
Disorder he spoke back to me in a really
poor Manner and we label those different
things and then we assume they are
different disorders and they certain
they're certainly different behaviors
and they might require different
interventions like one child might need
discipline and another maybe not but you
can you can solve the whole all of it by
feeding them yeah exactly I'm very
excited by
not just the presentation of these ideas
but hopefully the conversation and the
debate that this will produce and I'm
always so happy to have conversations
like this on the podcast because I hate
to say it folks but you need to be your
own Advocate you have to be your own
health Advocate and you cannot expect
other people to do it for you even the
best intentioned and most competent of
doctors the way things are currently
structured in our health care System
they may simply not have the available
bandwidth and time depending on where
and how they operate to do the requisite
research or quarterback some of the
exploration of these metabolic
interventions and see you really need to
take ownership radical ownership of your
own advocacy and this podcast your book
the resources that you'll have on your
website are some simple ways to do that
unfortunately also the mechanisms if you
take an afternoon to try to educate
yourself they are reasonably easily
understood I mean this is not
quantum physics we're talking about
which is not to minimize it in any sense
but you can gain a basic understanding
as a layperson
of the building blocks that you are
dealing with
and I should say also because this is
important that
that brain energy is not solely focused
I know we've dedicated a lot of time to
the ketogenic diet but it explores many
other levers and factors so not just
diet and not just the ketogenic diet
within diet but exercise relationships
removing metabolic toxins there are
there are other levers that you can pull
with the objective of this type of
metabolic
reboot or metabolic Rejuvenation
and I suppose I would ask just a few
questions in closing and one is knowing
what you do of exercise having looked at
that as a variable
are there any particular forms of
exercise that seem to demonstrate
Effectiveness for mitochondrial health
or addressing some of the conditions
that you're used to seeing as a
clinician
at this point we don't have great
evidence across the board for exactly
which one so there's one large study
over a million Americans that looked at
exercise as a prevention tool for mental
illness poor mental health and what they
found was that group Sports cycling
gym activities were best
and and I think the theme is cardio
and
pairing exercise with relationships
pairing exercise with social contact and
so you're getting a twofer with that one
you're getting some bonding and
friendships and other things so
I would say those are great
the research on exercise is a treatment
for mental illness is actually very it's
a mixed bag and some meta-analyzes have
actually found that exercise does not
appear to be an effective treatment for
mental illness
and I talk about some of the confounding
variables in that and one of the biggest
ones
is it a lot of medications that impair
mitochondrial function
which include a lot of psychiatric
medications but also include like
diabetes medications and some others
if you're taking medications that impair
mitochondrial function
those people do not get the same
benefits from exercise as people not
taking those medications
and we have decent studies
randomized controlled Trials of like
older adults
exercising half of them get metformin
half of them don't
the ones who did not get metformin had
more mitochondrial benefits and
adaptations than the ones who got
metformin yeah that's interesting and we
know that metformin appears to impair
mitochondrial function at least in in
some people in many ways but again when
it comes to psychiatric patients
antipsychotics and others or even more
powerful so with that said I think the
one thing I would say is zone two
training
so let me just let me just go to zone
two training and
we know that if you improve mitochondria
you know quantity quality
that even if you're just doing it in the
muscle cells that translates to brain
benefits and you actually get more
mitochondria and you actually get more
neuroplasticity in the brain as a
consequence of improving your muscle
size
and probably zone two training is the
be-all end-all if you have enough time
to do a lot of different types of
exercise I would absolutely say mix it
up do some cardio zone two training
maybe include some high intensity but
also you know do some isometrics try to
grow your muscles as large as you can
or as large as you want
and sure do some stretching and stress
reduction yoga other things those can be
helpful too all the things yeah
all right zone two training folks get
after it and I will say also there is
there's a book it is somewhat outdated
but for people who are interested in the
sum of the growth factor adaptations
related to exercise like release of
brain Drive neurotrophic factor and
things like that there is a book uh it
is older so I I don't it I don't
recommend it unreservedly because I
think that there have been recent
discoveries that would probably modify
it but called spark the Revolutionary
new science of exercise in the brain
this is from 2013.
so I think that
it's worth reading at least a Wikipedia
entry on but
Zone 2 training and I will also just add
to that
that
for people who may or may not recognize
the word metformin I just want to
underscore something and again feel free
to interject there's there's no
biological free lunch guys like if you
take a drug that has a high amplitude of
effect in X chances are that's not
completely isolated within this complex
closed system known as the human body so
there are people who have used metformin
for Life Extension purposes and I have
long been this is based on conversations
with Scientists to focus on Metformin
skeptical of The Upside benefit of using
Metformin if you are in reasonably good
metabolic shape
and this example you gave just goes to
show
it is not just naive but it is sometimes
dangerous certainly not without risk to
take drugs like this and for people who
have no context I believe metform is
predominantly used as a as a medication
and type 2 diabetes is that absolutely
yes type 2 diabetes yeah and it's
probably off patent now and generics are
everywhere I don't know but I think it
was a glucophage or glucophage I don't I
never know how to say that autophagy
macrophage I guess so glucophage is that
right am I getting that pronunciation
right I always screw it up one of the
two anyway you guys get the idea but if
you're repurposing drugs which many
people are and you got to be careful and
some of them are very interesting like
rapamycin which is an immunosuppressant
that is not a joke
does exhibit some life extension
in various species and animal models but
you got to be careful before you
introduce sort of a red hot variable
like that you got to do lots and lots of
homework so anyway that that's a good uh
cautionary note as well so
is there anything you'd like to to add
to that before we begin to wind I think
the only thing I'd like to add to the
last thing you said is that if you've
got type 2 diabetes and you're on
Metformin there's almost no doubt
metformin is the best drug for you to
probably be taking agreed if you need a
drug however I would also encourage you
if you've got Type 2 Diabetes Type 2
diabetes can be reversed you can use
dietary strategies especially low carb
or ketogenic dietary strategies to
reverse your diabetes get off medication
and dramatically improve your health
I have seen it time and again and
actually I did it with my father and it
was nothing short of miraculous for him
so yeah I'll just add another side note
which is probably going to get me in
trouble so I'm going to say it again
folks I'm not a doctor I don't play one
on the internet however one of the
reasons I wish it were easier to study
extended fasting in humans which way
back in the day you could I mean there
were some astonishing studies with
extended fasting and then that changed
but I have multiple anecdotes I
recognize the plural of anecdote does
not equal randomized control you know
controlled trial however
I have numerous anecdotes of people I
have direct contact with probably five
or six now who have seemingly
regenerated their pancreas's ability
through I guess what the beta ISO cells
to produce insulin as long-term type 1
diabetics using one month of fasting per
month so for five to six months they do
the first first week of the month
fasting for five to six months and in
multiple cases it appears
to be the case that some people regain
the ability to produce at least small
quantities of insulin and that
I think is
thought to be probably entirely
implausible uh by most folks out there
but this this is why I'm so excited to
be engaged with the science my
Foundation supports so much science
because we just don't know there are so
many open questions and in the meantime
that gives me all the more excitement
about
books like yours brain energy subtitle
revolutionary breakthrough at
understanding mental health and
improving treatment for anxiety
depression OCD PTSD and more because you
are discussing interventions that have
in the vast majority of people very
limited downside risk
and that are compatible with
many other therapies they don't need to
be a monotherapy it's not either or is
that fair to say I mean it seems fair to
say and that's part of why I'm so
enthusiastic about this absolutely I
think that we definitely have a mental
health crisis in the world today I mean
record Sky High record numbers of people
suffering from depression anxiety
burnout
Etc and there's no question that a lot
of the strategies
that
that I've discussed in the book will
address those easy cases I think the
much more shocking and revolutionary
thing is that I'm also talking about
things like bipolar disorder which you
are again you are a perfect
Testament to so many people that if you
have bipolar disorder you do not have to
be disabled for life from it you do not
have to take pills that are going to
make you overweight or obese type 2
diabetic impaired cognitively you can
find other strategies to address bipolar
disorder you are simply a model
person who figured it out on your own or
you talked to Great smart people who
you know gave you hints along the way or
whatever I don't know how the hell you
figured it all out but you are a shining
example for lots of people and what I
want to say is for all of you who know
somebody with schizophrenia or bipolar
disorder who are not like Tim Ferriss
there is a better way
so I really appreciate you saying that I
have had a lot of help along the way and
as I've had help I have tried to
showcase the people who have helped me
on this podcast and I think your work is
going to help so many people and it took
me a long [ __ ] time to grope through
the darkness to find certain tools and
what
what made me so Resolute in my desire to
have you on the podcast is I I listened
to you and I looked at the case studies
and I listened to the case studies and I
looked at the interventions and I said
for [ __ ] sake pardon my French but
you have assembled many of the tools
that took me decades to stumble into
eventually and then assemble into some
type of portfolio for myself and
for God's sake if I can save
people a whole bunch of time and angst
and
Maybe
help them reduce the frequency or
intensity or duration of their episodic
experiences of these conditions
then I'm all for it and the easiest way
I can do that is to have somebody like
you on the podcast so Chris I really
appreciate you taking the time and
people can find you on Twitter and
Instagram at chrispalmer MD all thanks
Chris Palmer at Chris Palmer and that's
my phrasing not yours Chris
palmermd.com the book again is brain
energy subtitle revolutionary
breakthrough and understanding mental
health and improving treatment for
anxiety depression OCD PTSD and more I
would emphasize the end more because as
we've mentioned multiple times really
using the uh usually I'm gonna really
make the most of this preschool example
just because the kids are all behaving
differently if they didn't eat in three
hours
it is entirely possible that there is a
shared underlying cause so why not
attempt to address that especially
when the downside risk is minimal and
the approach is the implementation is
known there are many ways to approach
these things so Chris thank you again I
really appreciate you taking the time
and I am very optimistic that your work
and this book will help many many people
thank you Tim thanks for everything
you've been doing and you continue to do
thank you and for everybody listening
we'll link to everything in the show
notes so all the names various studies
Etc the book of course and everything
else we'll link to as usual in the show
notes at Tim dot Blog podcast and until
next time be just a little Kinder than
necessary and that includes being kinder
to yourself if your compassion does not
include yourself it is incomplete thank
you for tuning in